foreign
accused serial killer breaking his
silence with our 8 news now
investigators good evening I'm Denise
Valdez and I'm Brian Loftus police say
Alonzo Brown killed three people three
men in three separate shootings earlier
this year so now brown is talking about
the potential of being put to death only
with our 8 news now investigator David
charns
but police say this now 19 year old did
investigators believe Alonso Brown shot
and killed three men between January and
June so what's your message to people
who are going to see this and think that
you are an accused serial killer
um I'm certainly not as accused serial
killer I'm just a 19 year old young man
trying to figure out life police say
brown lived near the crime scenes in the
Southeast Valley they believed he shot
and killed the man he knew in January
during an argument then in may they say
he shot and killed a man who was waiting
at this bus stop in June a second random
murder police putting it this way the
suspects seemed to stalk the victim
you're telling me that you are not the
person who killed these three men
no sir I'm not from jail Wednesday Brown
says it's not him in these suspect
photos police say they found Brown's DNA
on gloves and a jacket nearby Brown says
he bought that jacket from somebody else
[Music]
a family member telling police in June
Brown wore the jacket police also
finding other clothing items in what
they called a homemade fire pit at his
house so if you didn't do it who did
um
I'm a winning feel right me myself put
in the person's name out there officers
discovered a gun in Brown's underwear
during his arrest that gun they say is
connected to at least two of the
murderers with life in prison or the
death penalty on the table if he's
convicted Brown remains insistent
a homicide right now because of those
three murder charges Brown is being held
without bail his trial is scheduled to
begin next year outside the Clark County
Detention Center I'm David charns 8 news
now and police just charged Brown for
that January murder our Channel 8
investigators working to get more
information about what happened how
police say they connected Brown to the
crime